hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com
so i'm leaving tonight guys i'm going
back to france uh to see my family
for a wedding then i go to croatia guys
on the boat i'm gonna try to keep
updating you during my whole trip and i
told you that i will make one more video
before going so you guys can have it for
friday's open
so let's get into it let's analyze amc
press action
all right guys let's start on the forest
time frame as usual in this video i want
to make things
a little bit different so basically
nothing much happened right but still we
have a lot of
information from this nothing much that
happened but still have a lot of
information
from nothing much actually happening so
i'm gonna show you this i'm gonna show
you as usual guys the different
signals that i have or information that
i can use i'm gonna show you
what kind of method exactly i use to
process this information and tell you
what are my different scenarios
and the reasons why and i'm gonna of
course select the preferred scenario as
i always do
so in my previous video i told you guys
that here we have this triangle
where the breakout already occurred guys
the breakout occurred
at the 51 level
all right and you know it's a breakout
because you have a strong
move up with strong associated volume
right so this is a definition
of the breakout if your breakout has no
volume then it's not a breakout it's
just
a strong move up that can happen but
it's very important to know
if yes or not it's a breakout because if
it's a breakout then usually it's
getting re-tested as we have here 51 was
the breakout we tested it
let's say it was 51.5 roughly so 51.52
we we tested it one two three four times
alright
four times we came back here and four
times uh there was
a strong bank power at this level and
then we had the rebound
why do you have the strong bank power at
this level yes it's just a psychological
mechanism that happens to the bulls that
actually
didn't go in the straight here you know
for example i wouldn't go with this
trend if i was trading amc
at that time i would have waited for the
retest you know so it's people like me
that got in in the street here or people
who don't know about technical analysis
and that just you know they remember
that 51 was an amazing level because it
was the lower
level they saw during this whole bullish
day
so they remember that uh if i could be
in this
trade at the beginning of this very nice
and bullish day i would have been so
happy so i'm gonna try
to make it happen i'm gonna try to get
into the strain at this
lower level that i've seen that day so
this is the reason why the breakout is
very often retested after the breakout
occurred
now what i want to show you guys here so
there are a lot of things i want to show
you a lot of things i'm going to try to
do everything because there is
actually a lot of information for me
here to analyze then
i want to show you maybe the alternative
labeling that we could have here which
actually doesn't change much and by the
way guys i have
my discord it's in the description of
this video just click on the link
and you can access freely like for now
everything is for free
to all the different chats that we have
i did that so that
at least during my whole days i can
communicate with you and share any
information
that i see on the market and in this
chat actually in this discord
one of you guys that posted a picture of
amc with the triangle like this
and i immediately said yes this is a
very nice triangle
i totally agree with that and it's
actually coming
roughly to the same outcome as mine so
there are two major differences the
first difference is that first you
didn't have the breakout yet
so basically you couldn't have used 51
as an entry level
doing my triangle you could have done
this all right
so this is i think it's good to make
your signals happen
early but the earlier they happen the
less likely
they are to actually be good so it's
also good sometimes to wait
but the more you wait the higher you're
going to enter your trend if you want to
enter this trade
so anyway here the difference is that
the breakout has not occurred yet
and we're actually waiting for something
like this oh funny
it's actually you know exactly the same
thing that i want to see
because for me if we do this it means if
we break 64 it means that this abc
pattern
is complete for sure and that we are in
the third wave of this one two three
four five
here in purple this one so basically two
different methods
give you the same levels either we are
still in the force wave and we want to
have a breakout of this
downward sloping trendline around the 63
okay the level is slightly lower all
right so it gives you an area between 63
and 65 for
example and we want to see a breakout of
this pattern so that the fifth wave can
start
in my scenario the breakout already
occurred we are already in the fifth
wave so
you know it's like
we are ready in the fifth wave so it's
basically doing the same thing but just
a bit earlier
and also the other difference is that i
already have one more one too
that if you take the other scenario this
one to here
remember what i told you guys before i
told you that here we have a one two and
then the two is very big
to me this means that the fixed wave is
extended so once again
here we're gonna have a slight
difference if i take this triangle
i'm gonna have probably a higher target
than if i take for example this triangle
i mean it depends maybe i'm gonna have
some one two and some more extensions
coming here
let's see but basically both labelings
are valid for me they're both good to
use and i'm actually
keeping an eye as well on this trend
line even if i put my triangle like this
i still have a trendline here that is
full of information and of course
that this breakout is going to be
important and it's gonna be you know for
two reasons for me it's gonna be like
the end of the abc and for this triangle
it can be the end of the strangle as
well
so it's for me two different ways to
actually find the same
signals i wanted to put myself a bit in
the shoes of
a bear and i want to see how would i
feel
if i was actually shorting amc what
would i be
looking for and would i be happy of what
i'm seeing so the first thing
here is that you know what i like to do
i like to see who is winning the battles
you know every day we have a battle
between bears and booze
and the one that is winning the more
battle is the one that is actually in
control
especially when you have the volume with
you so just look at this this is the
whole consolidation phase that started
after we hit
73. so i'm counting the red days one
two three four five six seven
eight nine and how many green days one
two three
four five six seven so there are more
red days which makes sense because we're
actually correcting this is a force wave
so which is like a wave that is supposed
to be
controlled by bears but you can see that
the volumes especially
in the last days the volume of the green
days
are higher than the volume of the red
days so even
when they are supposed to be in control
they are
losing the big days and they almost
didn't win more days than the last
so basically this false wave is very
very strong
and this is where i wanted to bring you
in
actually what is happening right now
guys is what we call
build up so let me show you what is a
buildup and what it means
i'm gonna keep my labeling and maybe in
the future i'm gonna change it depending
on the new waves i'm gonna have
it doesn't really matter for now you
know for now i'm keeping it like this
because it gave me a nice breakout level
that actually gave me a very nice
reaction
so i'm happy about it so i'm keeping it
like this i want to explain to you guys
what is happening here so basically here
you can add one more indicator that is
called the realized volatility
and you can see that the realized
volatility that is here
so right now you have four numbers here
you can see check on the left
so you have the five 15 30 and 60 days
realized volatility right now the five
days which is the weekly realizable
activity
is at 48 and you can see that basically
for amc is
quite low 48 if you divide this by 16
is roughly three percent move every day
which is not a lot
and you can see that usually during
actually the consolidation phases during
this
phases where you have the buildup where
basically bullish investors they want to
get
in the amc trade and they are just you
know increasing
in size and in levels they're buying
orders
it usually creates a lower realized
volatility because
the momentum is shifting down as you can
see here all right this is the macd
but the bulls are actually buying the
deep very early you know
because they are very strong they are
actually in control even
in the false wave that should be
controlled by bears
so even here if i was a bear i would
feel bad because i can see that i'm not
winning battles
so one more sign that you have false
wave that is
just a consolidation where you have some
build up of long position
before the fifth wave is this realized
volatility that is low and is also of
course guys divergences
because when the momentum is shifting
down all right like here you can see the
macd so let me get rid of the volume we
saw that they are low which is
basically showing that nothing much is
happening but still when nothing much is
happening and the bears should be in
control it's a
win battle for the bulls guys and here
the momentum indicator is shifting down
all right that makes sense
but look usually during this build up
consolidation phases we have
some bullish hidden divergences which
one is it
it's this one guys the momentum
decreasing and
the price action not able to make a new
law actually making a higher low
why because bulls are putting their
buying orders
higher and higher because they are a bit
for more they want to be in the trade
and this is showing that even when the
momentum is going down when the bears
should be in control
they are not they can't make a new law
because you have this buildup orders
that are located around the 51 52
53 55 area and they are
actually going higher those buying
orders that are increasing guys
so usually when you have this the market
is losing momentum like here
you can see for example between here so
on the hourly
i don't have divergence but i have a
small hidden bullish divergence on the
forest and frame it's not perfect guys
all right but i just want to show you
this
because it's true for every stock every
situation crypto of course as well
is just you know showing you it's a sign
of who is
really in control divergences are used
for that
and here you can see that boots and
controls guys in on amc it's like
the macd is actually making a flat but
let me check maybe the rsi
you know it can work as well between
here and here it's saying rsi is
basically the same level so here we
don't have this divergence but usually
you have it and we almost have it
so the market is making new higher lows
with the macd going lower so this is a
very
bullish sign guys and we almost have it
here so and one more thing i wanted to
show you guys about
build ups because this this is basically
what is happening here so we are in the
force wave
we are consolidating we almost have some
bullish hidden divergences the market is
unable to make
low lows so basically we are in
ascending
triangle i mean it's a converging
triangle you can do it here or here
whatever
but you can see that basically we don't
have any bearish signal the red days are
lower in volume and they are almost not
more red days than green days which is
actually very bullish
during a wave that is supposed to be a
consolidation and a bearish wave
so basically we're moving here more
sideways than
on the downside and look guys when i try
in my bible to find some information
about buildups
i just have build and i checked and here
i just have you know
elliot telling us something about about
fourth
waves so let's read it because it's for
sure interesting
false waves are predictable in both
depths and
form because by alternation they should
differ from the previous second wave
of the same degree remember guys when
the second wave is
zigzag then the fourth wave is usually
flat and
anyways the false wave is very often a
triangle all right
and it's actually quite predictable
because usually it's retracing to the
top of the third
out the bottom of the force wave of the
preceding wave counting
more often than not they trend sideways
all right so this is what we're having
building the base for the final fifth
wave move you understand what is
happening
this is just a buildup phase a build up
consolidation phase
where bulls actually in control and
bears are scared
lagging stocks build their tops and
begin declining during this wave
since only the strength of a third wave
was able to generate an emotion in them
in the first place
okay whatever what is important guys is
just
that i wanted to show you that every
sign
we have every information that we can
see on this chart is telling us the same
thing
is that this is a false wave that is
almost finished or maybe already
finished and that we have
some build up some bulls that are buying
more and more before the fixed wave so
basically if i am a bear
i'm losing the big days so the days with
the big volumes are lost
i didn't win more days than i lost
during a phase where i should win i'm
not able to make a new law
so basically i'm desperate i'm scared
and i'm gonna find
a level where i'm gonna tell myself okay
above this level it's too strong
i'm out of this trend i don't want to
lose everything
and this level would be once again guys
you can do this
in a very brutal way
you just go on a daily timeframe this
can work as well you know for for you
guys that maybe i'm new to technical
analysis you can just do this you look
at this and you find roughly
the level above which you know the
overhead resistance kind of and here
just by putting it randomly i have 64.2
so once again all the different methods
we used so i prefer to do you know
something more precise
you know guys that i like technical
analysis a lot and
i'm trying to use some more
sophisticated kind of
tools so it's trendline as well but i
zoom in more
and for example another reason that for
me 64 is the resistance that we need to
trade above is that it's the maximum of
my b
wave here so using this abc pattern
i know that if we go above the b wave
then the abc
is for sure complete so you have
different methods that give you 63 64
64.5 you know so this is the breakout
and i'm gonna tell you guys if we go
there
once again with enough momentum the
momentum is very important we need
to make a big reversal we need to come
with nice momentum
so if we do that if we trade above 64
you're gonna see that
all the bears they're gonna use their
stop loss the stop is gonna trigger
a very strong move up and it's gonna be
the day where the
third wave has really started and after
that things will go very quickly guys
very quickly
so once again here we're building up a
lot of bulls actually increasing the
positions
so if you want to build up uh you know
the levels guys the levels are
51 52 around this level but it's going
higher you know
you can also kind of try to make sure
trendline but it's not very clean i have
only two reactions and here we're
training above that
which is showing again guys that bulls
they're not waiting for the better level
to buy they just buy
you know they just buy they're very
strong let me show you quickly
the option data so we had
the new short interest guys 85 million
shares so
lower than 100 million chance we had
here so 15 million shares less 17
actually
so the regular shot interest comes goes
from 21
to 17 fair enough i don't care guys 50
million shares how many traded
every day for the past week 230 million
so do we care about 50 million shares we
don't all right
so the short interest is something that
is going to be important when the volume
is going to drop
but for now guys everyone is in the amc
trader
a lot of scalpers institutional clients
i showed you guys an article
about goldman sachs that is getting in
that things that it's only the beginning
of this frenzy you know on the reddit
stocks so amc gamestop they think it's
only starting so what do you think they
do
they're buying you know they're buying
just you know they just think that the
risk reward is
good i don't really care about here the
short interest dropping a bit
i'm more concerned about the loss of
gamma that we had here guys
so once again here i compute all the
exposure the synthetic short exposure
that i get from the option open interest
i take all the collapsions i compute the
delta
myself using black shells formula you
know these guys
write this formula and i come up with
every position
that is on every strike on every
maturity and here what
we can see is that the 145 strike
is growing it was 8 million it is now 9
or 10 million
9.8 million actually million shares that
are
equivalent that are on the strike so
it's growing but it's not at
the spot you know the spot is around 60
and here i don't have that much gamma
so for example if amc goes from 58 to 18
you know the short interest only goes
from 10 to 11
all right so it's not a lot but once
again guys
those numbers that big but
what is really big to me is the volume
traded every day this
is insane and so the bullish momentum
comes off
of course from the market makers and
hedge funds that are cutting the
position
but it also comes from a lot
a lot of buyers of people
probably professional of the markets
that are you know trading buying sending
and they're just
trying to you know get into this trend
and make some profits and they're
helping the price action to go higher
and so i'm not that concerned by this
drop
of gamma but i want to see guys
i want to see those 145 call strike call
growing it's going to give me more
information that
the fifth wave is about to start
and to be huge so guys that's it for me
i hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys